The SCP Foundation has gone up against a lot
of anomalies that can best be described as…
demonic.
But few fit the bill better than the demons
and imps of SCP-5049, Demon Dan’s Discount
Homonculus Depot, a skin-stealing enterprise
designing bespoke demonic disguises on the
behalf of Seven Mysterious Demon Lords.
Anyone that the Foundation has managed to
capture related to this
anomaly has been assassinated
by the Demon Lords, eliminating the prospect
of further investigation.
But what if the Foundation brought in another
expert to help?
A bonafide expert in the occult.
DC’s devious demon detective himself, John
Constantine.
Maybe he can finally give us the lead we need
to bring down those Demon Lords once and for
all.
And with the help of the Anom-O-Tron 6000,
we’re going to find out exactly how that
situation would play out.
Let’s rev up the machine and take a look!
It was a cold night in New York; if you’ve
ever been there, you’ll know that most nights
are.
But, on this particular night, a certain chill
was streaking its way through the air, as
icy cold as the grave.
This wasn’t just a deathly gust of wind
or any other freak occurrence of the weather
though, especially judging by that piercing,
wailing shriek it gave as it passed by, a
cry loud enough to wake both the living and
the dead alike.
And hot on its tail, chasing
through the rain-dampened
streets after it, long trench coat whipping
behind him, was the one man stupid enough
to try and catch it.
You see, this thing he was chasing was a spirit;
some might have called it a Banshee or a Yonaki
babā, but all our coat-clad friend called
it was a ‘right bloody nuisance’.
As for who in Heaven, in Hell or on Earth
he was?
That’s easy.
If you were to rummage through the pockets
of his coat, you’d find the answer, along
with an interesting assortment of mystical
objects.
Beneath the charms and trinkets that he carried
on his person was a crumpled off-white business
card.
Printed on its surface, in simple black lettering
was one name: John Constantine.
And underneath, along with a phone number,
were the words ‘Exorcist, Demonologist and
Master of the Dark Arts’ – although the
word ‘master’ had been crossed out, with
‘Petty Dabbler’ written above.
Our friend John really hated putting on airs.
He turned down an alleyway, just as the spirit
did, its screams rippling through the silence.
Dead end, there was nothing but a solid wall
ahead.
Not that it mattered, the shrieking entity
lacked a physical, corporeal form, but the
sight of an obstacle in its path caused it
to pause, just for a split second, a short
moment, as it tried to think: over or through?
And that tiny little instance of hesitation…
well, that’s what John had been waiting
for.
As he ran towards the spirit, he reached into
his coat pocket, pulling out a lighter.
Its surface was engraved with a phrase in
Latin, that read: ‘Fiat iustitia, et pereat
mundus’, meaning ‘Let justice be done,
though the world may perish’.
That had long been John’s credo, to stop
at nothing to achieve righteous justice, no
matter what the cost or how bad things got.
Admittedly, that was a little easier to accomplish
when you owned a blessed lighter.
Striking it, John breathlessly uttered an
incantation to command the holy fire within.
His hand caught ablaze as he took hold of
the flame, barely feeling the pain of it burning.
Casting it towards the screeching spirit,
a bright orange streak shot forward and ensnared
the runaway creature.
It hovered above the ground, writhing and
thrashing in the air as it struggled to free
itself from its fiery bonds.
Shaking his hand to extinguish it, John reached
into his other pocket, looking for the small
jar he’d put there.
To his horror, the glass container was gone.
Constantine frantically patted the outside
of his coat, trying but unable to find it.
He must have dropped it during their chase,
and without the jar, he had nothing to trap
the spirit in.
“Typical,” he grumbled to himself, turning
to look at the shrieking specter wriggling
its way out of the flame.
John looked around for something, anything
he could use to contain it.
Finally, he spotted something left discarded
in the alleyway; it was an empty whiskey bottle,
filthy and covered in grime.
“Well, s’pose this’ll have to do!”
Constantine said aloud to no one other than
himself; he was a bit of a fan of his own
voice, even if his overconfidence did regularly
cross the line into arrogance.
Placing the bottle neck-up on a dry patch
of the ground, John hurriedly pulled a piece
of chalk from his pocket.
He started to mark the asphalt, creating a
circle around the bottle, symbols taken from
ancient languages and magical texts surrounding
the unlikely vessel.
His hands at his sides, Constantine took a
deep breath and began muttering in Aramaic;
to the untrained ear, it would have sounded
like an incomprehensible incantation, although
in no uncertain terms, John was just telling
the spirit to ‘pack it in and get in the
bottle before you wake the whole city’.
With a final screech of dissatisfaction, the
entity was pulled into its cramped new home,
like a mystical vacuum cleaner sucking up
a cloud of dust.
With an exhausted sigh, John knelt down to
pick up the bottle.
The glass surface was warm to the touch now
that the shrieking spirit was contained inside.
He yawned, putting the bottle in the pocket
of his trench coat; he had a nice cosy shelf
back in the House of Mystery where he could
keep this troublesome siren and let it gather
dust, trapped and unable to cause harm to
any mortal ever again.
But it was just as John was preparing a spell
to transport himself back
to his base of operations
that his cell phone started to ring.
“Hello?” he answered bluntly; he was too
tired for whatever this was.
“Um, hi.
Is that Mr Constantine?”
a female voice asked from the other end of
the line.
“Depends on who wants to know, love,”
John replied.
“My name’s Emma.
A friend of mine gave me your card, they said
that…” she paused, sounded like she was
sniffling.
“They said you could help me get my brother
back.”
As much as it had already been a long night,
and even though he might often act like he
didn’t care, John was rarely heartless enough
to turn down a request for his help.
Giving another sigh, John told Emma he’d
look into it, but she’d need to give him
the full story in person.
The coffee shop was one of the few open this
early, as morning started to dawn over the
city.
All of New York was gearing up for another
day of hustle and bustle, people shoving past
each other to get the subway to jobs they
hated.
Stepping inside with his usual air of swagger
and bravado, John spotted Emma sitting and
waiting for him.
She had a mug of coffee in her hands, but
wasn’t drinking it; the lack of steam seemed
to indicate it was already stone cold.
“You must be Emma,” he greeted her, doing
his best impression of a friendly smile, extending
a handshake.
“John Constantine, at your service.”
“Oh, hello,” Emma responded, awkwardly
accepting the shake.
“You sure I can’t get you anything stronger?”
John offered as he sat down opposite.
“Stronger?
It’s eight o’clock in the morning, isn’t
it a bit early for that?”
she asked.
“Never too early in my book,” John chuckled
dryly, picking up a menu and scanning his
eyes over it.
“Here we are, breakfast!
One should never battle demons on an empty
stomach.
So, what can I do for you, Emma?” he asked,
not even looking up from
the menu, still half-focused
on what he was going to order.
“Well,” Emma began.
“Like I said over the phone, something happened
to my brother.”
“Run off, did he?”
Constantine interjected.
“Yes.
And no.
Not exactly,” she sounded confused, like
she was aware that what she was attempting
to describe wouldn’t make any sense when
said out loud.
“He did disappear, for a few days actually.
We’ve been living together since our parents
died, in this tiny little apartment, so we
can tell when one of us has left.
It was like, one moment he was there, the
next he wasn’t.”
“Sounds like a pretty run-of-the-mill missing
persons case, love,” John sighed.
“Not exactly my department.
You’re best off going to the coppers for
something like that.”
“I tried that!”
Emma raised her voice slightly, getting agitated…
or scared.
“I told the cops Ethan was missing, and
they filed a report.
But they dropped the case when he…”
John thought about making another snide comment
to get her to finish her sentence, but chose
to wait instead.
“He came home, just like that, a few days
later.
The police questioned Ethan and asked him
where he’d been, and he just told them he
had gone to a hotel for a few nights,” she
explained.
“Open and shut, then,” John shrugged.
“Except… the thing that came back, it’s
not my brother,” Emma continued, trying
to hold back frightened tears.
“It looks like him, and it even sounds like
him, but… it’s not Ethan.”
“You think something happened to him?”
Constantine pondered.
“Maybe.
I don’t know about… possessions and demons
and all that stuff, but I was told you might
be able to help.”
“As much as I’d love to help you out,
I’m afraid I need a little more to go on
than that,” John admitted, a tiny shred
of sympathy in his tired eyes.
“I recorded this!”
Emma exclaimed, producing her phone.
“That’s part of what made me call you,
since he came back Ethan…
well, not Ethan, he started staying up late
at night.”
“Doing what, exactly?”
the paranormal detective asked.
“Chanting,” she answered, hitting play
on her phone.
The audio recording started, it was faint,
but John could just about hear someone growling.
It was a human voice, male as expected, but
it sounded all wrong.
Ethan, or whatever was pretending to be him,
was making noises closer to that of a wild
animal than a person, speaking in a garbled,
unintelligible tongue that sounded distinctly…
demonic, to John’s experienced ears.
“What was he doing the night
before he disappeared?”
he asked after a solemn moment’s pause.
“Just sitting at home, watching TV, nothing
out of the ordinary,” Emma answered.
“But specifically,” John said with urgency
in his voice.
“What was he watching?”
“I…
I don’t know!”
she exclaimed.
“He was just flicking through channels,
but there was hardly anything on that late
except… ads.”
Leaning back in his seat, John tutted to himself,
shaking his head.
“Demon Dan, you old codger,” he muttered.
“Who’s Demon Dan?”
Emma asked.
“I’m so sorry, love,” John replied,
dodging the question.
“But your brother’s gone.
And right now, there’s some nasty blighter
from the pits of Hell itself using his skin
as its own personal human disguise.
We need to find it, and send ‘em all the
way down South.”
“South?”
Emma echoed, too confused to cry.
“You mean like… to New Jersey?”
John smirked dryly.
“Oh, much further than that, love,” he
chuckled.
“Now, where would Ethan usually be at this
early hour?”
“Normally, he isn’t up this early, he’ll
be asleep back at the apartment.”
“Perfect!”
Constantine clapped his hands and stood up
from the table.
“Ever seen an exorcism before?”
Hurriedly, Emma escorted John back to the
apartment she and her brother had shared.
There, they found Ethan – or rather, the
thing pretending to be him – seemingly laying
sound asleep.
It was only as John approached, hands raised
cautiously, that the disguised demon rose
and lunged at him, snarling like a rabid animal
again.
Luckily, while the entity within was a powerful
agent of darkness, the outer shell it was
wearing was still mostly human.
A quick blow from a frying pan connected with
‘Ethan’s head, thanks to Emma, and knocked
him out long enough for John to make preparations.
Clearing the floor, ripping up the carpet
to gain access to the floorboards below, John
and Emma shifted the unconscious Ethan into
the center of the room.
Around him, Constantine began marking out
a ritual circle on the woodwork.
He’d brought along his bag, producing a
series of candles from it, placing each one
at the points of a pentagram he drew within
the circle.
Buried in the bag were a few extra tools of
his many trades, some extra spell books, holy
water, and even some hallowed brass knuckles.
He pulled one of the knuckledusters out and
pocketed it; he hadn’t used them in a dog’s
age, but better to be safe.
“You didn’t answer before,” Emma chimed
in, watching the demonologist at work.
“Come again?”
John replied as he started painting runes
around the pentagram.
“When I asked you who Demon Dan was,”
she clarified.
“A right pain in the backside, I’ll tell
you that for nothing,” he chuckled.
“Think of him like the used car salesman
of the Underworld.
I’ve only ever heard stories mind you, I
wasn’t certain until you mentioned that
Ethan was watching ads on the telly.”
“So, what?”
Emma asked.
“This Demon Dan guy, he has his own commercials?”
“Spot on!”
John smirked.
“He runs some place called Demon Dan’s
Discount Homunculus Depot.
The ad appears on your TV, usually at random,
and then Dan starts hawking in wares.
You know, real salesman type, that whole
infomercial
lark.”
“What’s he selling, though?”
she cut in, her voice telling John she had
already half figured it out, but didn’t
want the answer to be as horrible as the one
in her head.
John paused for a moment, looking up from
the nearly-complete circle of occult symbols.
“Us,” he replied plainly.
“Human beings.
Once the ad’s over, the nearest door becomes
a gateway to his little corner of paradise.
Whoever sees it ends up there.
That’s when Dan hollows a person out, scoops
out their soul until they’re just a husk.
That’s what happened to poor Ethan here.”
Emma sniffled, holding back tears.
“But why?”
“Demons need vessels, love,” Constantine
answered.
“They can’t well be running about up here
in broad daylight.
That’s what Dan does, he takes them apart
and stitches them back up.
Turns human beings into bespoke skin vehicles
for the worst Hell has to offer.”
With the circle finally complete, John retrieved
one of his spell books and a vial of holy
water from his bag.
It was time.
Opening the book to the right chapter, he
splashed some of the blessed liquid over ‘Ethan’
laying in the middle of the circle.
Instantly he woke up again, growling angrily
as the water singed his skin like burning
acid.
Even through its disguise, it was still enough
to sting the demon.
It went to lunge at the English exorcist again,
only to find an invisible barrier blocking
its path – the spell John had cast was working,
keeping the monster contained… for now.
“You…” the demon gurgled from inside
its skin suit, lifting a finger to John.
“You are known to us, Constantine!”
“Oh yeah?” he replied sarcastically.
“My reputation has a habit of preceding
me.”
“Indeed,” the creature replied, chuckling
in a mocking fashion.
“We know what you’ve done.
Your transgressions, your mistakes…
oh, so many failures.
The great John Constantine, nothing but a
fraud.”
“That’s enough out of you, mate,” John
spat; flicking through the pages of his tome,
looking for the right incantation.
“Your mother and father…”
the demon growled.
“Mary Ann, Thomas… and Cheryl, your sister.
Was it worth it, John?
A spell to make you a powerful magician, was
it really worth the fire that claimed their
lives?”
John forced himself to ignore the demon’s
taunting, beginning to mutter a spell under
his breath.
All the while, he was aware that Emma was
standing next to him; he could see her concerned,
frightened look out of the corner of his eye.
“And then poor, defenseless Astra,” the
hellspawn continued.
“Practically handed over to Nergal on a
sliver platter, and all thanks to you, John.”
“I told you,” John smirked, finally reaching
the right passage.
“That’s enough!”
The whole room shook, books flying off shelves
as if the full force of an earthquake had
hit the apartment.
In fact, it was worse than that, it was as
though a tornado was blasting through the
place, magical gusts of wind throwing everything
into disarray.
Images bombarded Constantine’s mind, the
sights that Ethan would have seen the night
he was taken.
He could see the commercial on the TV, the
logo for Demon Dan's Discount Homunculus Depot
appearing on-screen in baby-blue bubble lettering.
Then, there was the monster himself, Demon
Dan, his dark green skin, patches of thick
brown fur appearing randomly over his body.
Next came the sight of the store itself, the
rows upon rows of hanging human corpses, all
hollowed-out shells ready for Dan’s demonic
customers to slip inside.
But all the while, John didn’t let up.
Slinging more holy water at the disguised
demon, he shouted the words to the spell as
loud as he could, repeating the entire passage
over and over.
Inside the circle, the creature thrashed and
growled, hovering above the ground as the
hellish host was forced out of Ethan’s remains.
“The Seven Lords are ever planning their
invasion!”
the demon snarled.
“You can’t stop what’s coming, Constantine!”
“If I had a quid for every time I heard
that,” John chuckled.
With a final, deafening crash, the body finally
dropped back to the ground, still and lifeless.
Emma couldn’t help but scream as she looked
at her brother, deflated, emptied inside,
and now left and little more than his empty
skin.
“No, time for that, love!”
Constantine urged her, pulling his phone from
his pocket and typing out an urgent ‘SOS’
text.
“Now we’re in real trouble!”
“What the hell do you mean ‘real trouble’?”
Emma yelled, sobbing uncontrollably as she
cradled Ethan’s hollow body.
“Well, Demon Dan’s not gonna be too pleased
when one of his customers complains about
what I just did,” John replied, checking
his phone; she hadn’t texted back yet, this
was an emergency.
“So, he’ll probably be here any second
now-”
Practically on-cue, the front door to the
apartment swung open, and out stepped Demon
Dan himself.
He towered over both John and Emma, almost
seven feet tall on his long goat legs, and
even uglier than he had looked on TV.
“I should have known!” he bellowed, showing
off rows of pointed teeth as he laughed.
“If it isn’t the Hellblazer himself.
You’ve got some nerve messing with my business,
little man!”
“And you’ve got some bloody cheek snatching
human beings for your little hustle, mate,”
John retorted, slipping something out of his
coat pocket as he squared up to the grotesque,
green-skinned demon.
“A few words of advice, lad.
Cash up, pack your bags, and close shop.”
Demon Dan threw his head back and laughed,
a twisted, inhuman sound.
“Or what?” he snarled with a grin.
“I’ve got a thriving enterprise.
Business is booming!
Do you really think you can stop me all alone,
Constantine?”
John smirked, feeling his phone buzz in his
pocket.
“Who said I was alone?”
A blast of magical energy lit up the apartment,
as a raven-haired woman appeared, in a black
tuxedo jacket and matching top-hat, a white
shirt and bow-tie beneath.
She gave a flick of her hand, right towards
Dan, casting a spell.
“Dnes mih ot yrotagrup!”
she yelled, all her words reversed.
Before the demonic salesman could comprehend
what was going on, a portal erupted behind
him, with enough force to drag him into it.
Demon Dan tried desperately to scrabble to
grip at the floorboards, only to feel a shoe
standing on his clawed fingers.
Looking down at him, John was wearing something
metal over his fingers.
“You’re out of business, mate.”
With a swing of his fist, the hallowed brass
knuckles smashed into Demon Dan’s face,
burning his green skin and sending him tumbling
backwards into the portal’s magical pull.
“You took your time,” John jokingly scolded.
“A ‘thank-you’ wouldn’t go a miss,
John,” Zatanna Zatara sighed.
“I didn’t have to come just because you
texted me.”
“Cheers,” Constantine said earnestly.
He knew that Demon Dan wouldn’t be gone
for long, but maybe a short stint in Purgatory
would at least put a halt
to the satanic salesman’s
schemes for the time being.
Although, swept up in the excitement of his
temporary victory, John didn’t notice Emma’s
eyes quickly flash an infernal shade of red.
Now go check out “SCP-738 THE DEVIL’S
DEAL” to be made an offer you won’t be
able to refuse.
Or, if you want more clashes between comic
book icons and creatures of chaos, then try
“DEADPOOL VS SCP-682” for more!